Film Courage: Is it important to know the
ending before you start writing your screenplays?
Van Ditthavong, Filmmaker/Photographer: I
mean I would love to know the ending all of
the time.
It will be awesome.
Sometimes I have it and sometimes it changes.
I would love to know as many parts of the
puzzle as I can.
Sometimes you discover it and it goes another
way.
I think that’s the beauty of sitting down
and chipping things away because it might
make more sense.
A lot of times it anchors things and having
an ending where you are concrete about it
helps.
But then you might fall in love with the characters
and you don’t want it to end that way, so
again trying to be flexible with that is good
in my opinion but knowing the ending would
be awesome and sometimes I have that in my
head and then you play around with the themes
and then you follow the themes and hopefully
you can direct everything toward the end.
That would be my process.
I don’t know what works all the time.
Film Courage: But as a rule it sounds like
you don’t always have to know the ending
before you begin something?
Van: Yes, I think so.
I think so.
It would be very helpful and it will just
guide but I think you have a gist of your
story and then if you gist then you probably
can get to the ending quicker than if you
don’t have that.
Film Courage: With ALL ROADS TO PEARLA did
you know the ending as you began?
Van: I had an idea of an ending.
Now knowing how to tie it all up it took me
awhile.
I remember I did have it where I knew how
I wanted it to end but how it ended was still
up in the air because there were so many loose
parts.
I think one of the things that I’ve found
even with the script in the early stages is
I don’t know if anyone out there has a similar
problem is your storylines, sometimes you’ve
got to wrangle them back and have that fit
and that was the tricky part and not make
it seem so forced and things and massage it
correctly and still get your message across
or what the story is about.
When I started I had an idea what’s going
to happen but without giving anything away
it was guided but the little details was harder.
Film Courage: Maybe help me understand that
so is it almost like if you’re going to
search for Halloween decorations but then
you go down this rabbit hole and now you are
searching fall [decorations]…and you go
“Wait, my original plan was to look for
Halloween decorations.”
Is that what you’re talking about where
you go…where you have to wrangle it back
in?
Van: Yes, like say for instance we had skeletons,
we had zombies, and we have ghosts but only
the ghosts is at the end.
What happened to the skeleton and the zombies
without it becoming…did we forget them at
the aisle 14 or did they disappear?
Or did the ghost take it?
So if you knew that the ghost is the one that’s
there at the end in the front yard because
then maybe you won’t want the zombies in
the back later.
You know you have the elements but you know
you thought you wanted the ghosts to be the
one that is the main highlight.
I think that is what I’m talking about.
More of like I have an idea I want the ghost
to be my the guy out there but what do I do
with the rest of the crew.
Film Courage: Interesting, okay…and do we
really need to know how much and why you’ve
left the skeleton in the aisle 14 or 14 [whatever]?
Van: That goes back to our discussion of do
you want to hand hold more or do you want
to leave it a little bit more obscure?
So do we leave a foot out and we see the skeleton
foot in aisle 14 or do you want the entire
leg out or do you want the entire body out
so you can see that the skeleton was hurt
in aisle 14?
That kind of stuff so that’s what I think
I’m talking about in terms of like have
an ending, I have a feeling ending, how do
I get there with all of these other things
that are happening?
But then sometimes you go you know what…actually
the skeleton should be the one that’s at
the end.
So that could happen.
But with ALL ROADS TO PEARLA I had a feeling
of what I wanted, my challenge was I knew
the last page.
My challenge was the 5 pages prior to that
last page.
That kind of thing) of tying things up and
getting it right and who is and how do we
get there to make it kind of dramatic and
suspenseful (things like that).
Question For The Viewers:
Will you start writing a screenplay if you
don’t know the ending?